the most responsible way to live is that
you're playful with life
it's absolutely irresponsible to carry a
long face and walk around in this planet
if you try to control the variety of
situations that may pop up in your face
tomorrow morning all that'll happen is
you will become a very limited life what
you call as human potential is not of
any kind of measurable limit it can go
as far as you desire or us as far as you
have the courage to walk
Juanes or get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best sadguru and the power of inner
engineering mentor me Sadhguru let's
kick it off with rule number one turn
inward you know you're here only because
you can see hear smell taste and touch
this is the only way you'll know that
you're here right now suppose you doze
off don't okay suppose you doze off you
don't know that you're here isn't it yes
even though you're here your heart is
beating everything is functioning the
world is on we are all here but you
won't know that you're here nor will you
know that I'm here or anybody else is
here isn't it yes all that's happened is
life is on full on even within you only
thing is these five sensory organs have
shut down so your entire experience of
life right now is happening because you
can see hear smell taste and touch just
look at the nature of the sensory organs
in the very nature their outward bound
isn't it can you roll your eyeballs
inward and scan yourself now this is a
shall I give you a bad example sir
your our nose is located now right above
our mouth suppose you don't brush your
teeth
for three days though this nose is right
here it won't tell you you have not
brushed your teeth the whole room will
know you have not brushed your teeth but
you will not know this is the human
predicament it's very easy to see what's
wrong with this guy what's wrong with
her what's wrong with her it's very it
takes a lot of observation to see what's
wrong with this that level of keenness
of observation is missing in most people
they need to cultivate that rule number
two be playful being playful always has
been understood as a responsibility
yes do you know right from your
childhood and probably to your children
also you're doing this if they're just
playful you think it's irresponsible the
most responsible way to live is that
you're playful with life it's absolutely
irresponsible to carry a long face and
walk around in this planet yes or no
isn't it absolutely irresponsible to
walk around with misery
yes that's the most irresponsible thing
you can do so being playful is not
irresponsibility bling being playful is
being very responsible and responsive to
life only when you are playful you can
do that when you're serious the world
doesn't exist for you you and your
nonsense yes when you're serious it's
just about you and your nonsense the
world and other life does not exist for
you only when you are playful you can
pay attention to everything you can
truly respond to everything in the world
only if you're playful otherwise you
cannot just the burden of it will kill
you also if you want to learn to have
more confidence check in my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link to
join is in the description below it's
easy to make a buck very hard to make a
difference rule number three be
well-managed
if you try to control the variety of
situations that may pop up in your face
tomorrow morning all that will happen is
you will become a very limited life you
would step out into the world and do
whatever that needs to be done only if
you have an assurance no matter what you
walk into you will not lose yourself you
will walk full stride otherwise you'll
only be a half a step most human beings
are half steps because the fear of
suffering if this happens what will
happen to me if that happens what will
happen to me if you're well managed
within yourself you know how to manage
your thought you know how to manage your
motion you know how to manage your body
your chemistry you energy if you know
how to manage all this what does it
matter if you walk into hell I'm asking
if you are well managed
if you are a heaven within you what does
it matter where you go
he'll also will be an interesting place
to go but if you are ill managed then
you want to be in a nice place all the
time you will not step out into anything
I am NOT saying this is wrong
this is against nature because in nature
every life is aspiring to a B as much as
it can be isn't it every life is
naturally aspiring this is not a
philosophy this is not an ideology that
you must do this or that it is natural
and intrinsic for every life that you
will do as much as it can from an
earthworm from a worm to an insect to a
bird to an animal to a tree every one of
them are trying to be full-fledged life
if you go against this simply because of
the fear of suffering then all
possibilities of exploring the nature of
being human
the tremendous immensity of being human
is just lost upon humanity today you
will see this everywhere when people say
I am only human they are talking about
the limitations of being human they are
not talking about the possibilities of
being human isn't it when if we are the
most intelligent species on the planet
if we are the most capable species on
the planet should we be talking about
our possibilities or should we be
talking about our limitations
whenever anybody writes or says oh we
are human they are always referring to
their limitations never to the
possibilities of being human this is
because the the most fundamental things
have not been taught in our education
systems how to handle your thought and
your emotion your psychological drama
has gone out of control it's a badly
directed drama believe me
if it is a well directed drama you would
take it to the conclusion that you want
isn't it because it's a badly directed
drama just about anybody can take charge
of it who is the director of your
psychological drama just about anybody
isn't it
anybody can make it into your tragedy
rule number four get in control what you
call as human potential is not of any
kind of measurable limit it can go as
far as you desire or us as far as you
have the courage to walk so when we say
human potential unleashing human
potential it is not about reaching the
peak it is a trajectory because what our
life is is a combination of a certain
amount of time and energy time is
rolling away for all of us at the same
pace if you sit it rolls away if you
sleep it rolls away if you do something
it goes away if you don't do anything it
goes away you're happy or miserable it
goes away time is running out for all of
us so it's only the energy that you can
do different things with if you bring
your energies to a certain level of
intensity and possibility what somebody
does in ten years you may do it in money
this means if you live here for hundred
years it feels like in people's in
impact that you're created it feels like
you lived here for a thousand years
simply because you have managed your
life energies in a certain way so for me
a human being being impactful means how
conscious have you become this is very
important because if you're in
compulsive cycles then your energy gets
wasted in so many things if you absorb
people in a day let's say let's take 24
hours in that anyway most people buy
prescription in America they sleep for
eight hours so eight hours means
one-third of life is gone in the
remaining two-thirds they have to eat
they have to you know shower
bathroom this that all this another two
three hours gone so literally 50% of
life is gone daily basis just for basic
maintenance of this life 50% of the time
is gone and maintenance remaining 50%
what they have if you look at every
single move that they may make with
their body their thought process their
emotions you will see a whole lot of it
is happening in compulsive cycles or in
other words if you a little sensitive to
life you will realize you are the
biggest issue in your life so this is
one thing that I'm trying to do with
people that you are never the issue in
your life I'm not the issue my thought
my emotion my body is never the issue my
thought my emotion my energy and my body
are my instruments of function they are
not impediments in my life but I would
say for 90% of the human beings their
own body then the compulsions of the
body the compulsions of their thought
the compulsions of their emotions are
ruling them most of the time so when you
yourself for a problem well you're on
self-help so how do you begin to break
out of that like if we're all stuck in
these compulsive patterns how do you
gain the consciousness that you're
talking about and begin to I don't know
if the words go beyond elevate like how
do you stop being in that endless cycle
everybody wants a solution but nobody
wants to delve into the problem and see
what is the nature of the problem that
we have the nature of the problem is
like this why are we compulsive what is
it that's compulsive about us compulsion
means we are going to the same place
again and again that means we're going
in circles the nature of physical
existence in the universe is such
whether you take an atom an individual
atom or the cosmic space everything
that's physical is always in cyclical
moment the atoms are doing their circles
the solar system is doing his stuff the
galaxies are doing
their staff our own bodies are going
through cycles in fact we are born
because of the cycles in our mothers
bodies that's why we are born so entire
physical nature is born out of cyclical
moment that means compulsiveness so do
not misunderstand compulsiveness as
something bad it's the basis of your
existence
it is a good platform but you're
supposed to stand on the platform and
act right now you have become the
platform so somebody else will dance on
you and we'll number fire the last one
before a very special bonus clip is make
the best out of every experience how to
address the larger issues of my life
there are no large issues in your life
what is the large issue that you are
talking about it is just about what job
to take which girl to marry
where to go for vacation whether whether
to get married or not get married you
know little things isn't it these are
not large issues these are the little
things in your life yes or is it just a
small thing whom I get married to I am
NOT saying it's a small thing but as an
issue it's a small issue little issue as
a consequence to your life yes it has
many things but this is something that
human beings have done for millions of
years
we have enough experience on these
things essentially we know that whatever
job we take whoever we marry it is just
a way we make out of it every experience
of life you can make it an enriching
experience every experience in your life
you can make a curse out of it see there
is nothing wrong in your job whatever
job you're doing there's nothing wrong
getting this job there's nothing
wrong and losing this job there's
nothing wrong in getting married there's
nothing wrong in getting the worst
there's nothing wrong in not getting
married there is nothing wrong in
anything there is nothing wrong in this
or that but it is just that you make
misery out of it
that's wrong if you do this you make
misery out of it if you do that you make
misery out of it that's what is wrong
with you so you got married is it wrong
that's not the point
there's nothing wrong with it you did
not get married is it wrong
no there's nothing wrong with it that's
wonderful too you got divorced is it
wrong no that's also wonderful it is
just that you make misery out of
everything that's what is wrong you just
address that one issue everything will
be settled now I've got a special bonus
script from Sadhguru on how to tell
great stories that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what would you do to be more playful
today question number two where do you
need to get in control and number three
how can you make the best of the
negative experience in front of you
right now on a certain day a bull and a
pheasant what grazing bull was chomping
the grass pheasant was picking off
picking ticks off the bull partnership
the huge tree at the edge of the field
the pheasant very nostalgically looked
at the tree and sad Oh alas there was a
time I could fly to the topmost branch
of the tree now I do not have inner
strength in my wing you want to get to
the first branch the bull very
nonchalantly said that's no issue just
heat a little bit of my dung every day
within a fortnight you'll get there
pheasant said come on what kind of
rubbish is that the bull said really try
and see the whole Humanity's on it
so very hesitantly the pheasant started
pecking a death down and lo on the very
first date reached the first branch of
the tree within a fortnight it reached
the topmost branch of the tree just
beginning to enjoy the scenery an old
farmer I was rocking on his rocking
chair saw a fat old pheasant sitting on
top of the tree pulled out his shotgun
and shot the bird off the tree the moral
of the story is many times even bulls
can get you to the top
but it never lets you stay there
[Music]
if you want to see sadguru's top 10 roof
success check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
just labor is not going to get you
somewhere right kind of action the right
timing right place all this is important